what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
things are about to get pretty crazy in
the mcu some of you may heard that
charles xavier is going to be in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
coming from the fox universe however
this is just one part of this report he
is not the only x-men or only fox
character that is going to be appearing
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness but there is going to be a
handful more which i'm going to talk
about in this video and of course i'll
explain charles xavier as well which
charles xavier it's going to be and why
why are these characters going to be in
this movie and why are they going to
fight the scarlet witch and sadly and
i'll just mention this now out of all
these characters that the scarlet witch
is supposed to fight in the film logan
was supposed to be one of them hugh
jackman's wolverine specifically however
according to a report from the user
viewer anon who has been extremely
accurate about some things that have
recently been proven true he said a
fight between wolverine and wanda was
supposed to happen where wolverine
actually lost but apparently it didn't
happen and this is according to him so
that's extremely sad that that's not
going to happen but it does give you
hope just a little bit that perhaps
maybe hugh jackman could return one time
and make an mcu cameo so now we've
really and i mean we've really moved
away from the marvel cinematic universe
and really stepped into the marvel
cinematic multiverse especially after
that spider-man no way home trailer
doctor strange literally mentioned the
multiverse and how him and peter parker
messed with it when they did the spell
well when doc strange did the spell and
of course we all know how loki ended it
ended with the birth or at least the
rebirth of the multiverse and there are
a few things that really have affected
the multiverse it's looking like it's
just not one event that is making
everything kind of go into madness it
looks like it was a few different events
wanda is a nexus bean so i'm sure
something that happened in one division
caused the nexus event we definitely
know that at the end of the loki series
what they did no spoilers in case
anybody hasn't seen it created the
multiverse and i'm assuming even if you
haven't seen it you've heard that loki
creates the multiverse i just won't say
how and like i said doctor strange just
pretty much straight up says we tampered
with the multiverse and then of course
we got those glorious shots of the
pumpkin bomb the lightning the sand the
lizard and of course doc ock confirming
that it's here it's in the mcu it has
begun and where everything is going to
start to get absolutely insane is in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness i mean we knew this the names
right in the title but it seems like we
don't know exactly how crazy it's going
to get but today we do get a little
closer as we have a pretty crazy but
pretty awesome report the first report
came a couple of days ago from daniel
rbk and i think a lot of people know
daniel rpk by now and know that he is
actually pretty reliable and the other
day he said in doctor strange 2 wanda
will fight someone from the fox verse i
am not allowed to reveal who it is but
it could top this fight in which he was
referring to doctor strange fighting
thanos in avengers infinity war now
daniel wasn't allowed to say but
somebody online did come out and say and
it's the user my time to shine hello and
just so you're aware this user is very
reliable about a week before the trailer
for no way home hit he posted everything
that we were going to see and it all
came true so clearly this person has
very very credible and real insider
information and he came out or she came
out and said yesterday it's going to be
charles xavier leading the multiversal
illuminati against wanda now if you've
been following my channel for a while or
if you're new i've been talking about
professor x being in multiverse of
madness for a long time and the
illuminati being in multiverse of
madness for even longer i actually
posted my first video about the
illuminati and professor x appearing in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness on january 3rd of 2020. this was
an exclusive scoop given to me by
gegacity mag owner mikey sutton then
several months down the road a lot of
other people started reporting this
saying they've heard it as well and now
we're here now i also knew professor x
was going to be in it and i do believe
that it's going to be patrick stewart
and a lot of people have been hinting at
this which gives it further proof but
the reason that i believe is because
patrick stewart actually came out and
said a little over a year ago that he
met with kevin feige i've talked about
this several times on my channel and
also talked about how since he met with
patrick stewart he probably also met
with ian mckellen and hugh jackman as
well and maybe some others patrick
stewart came out and talked about it a
little bit and basically said i met with
kevin feige to talk about plans for
professor xavier so literally right
there admitting that kevin feige did
want professor x in the mcu now patrick
stewart did say that his time as
professor x was done he ended that with
logan he said goodbye to the character
but here's the thing about doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
it's literally a multiversal illuminati
team it's not an illuminati from our
main timeline so he can still play
professor x and not undo anything that
he did in logan he doesn't have to undo
his goodbye and from what we've been
hearing for the past two days he is
going to lead an illuminati team and it
seems like we might know who that team
is according to user viewer anan who i
mentioned has been very accurate with
leaks in the past he says or she says i
don't know if this is a final list and i
will stress as always to take things
with a grain of salt but here is who
i've heard make up the illuminati in
multiverse of madness professor x
captain carter balder the brave monica
rambo and mordo now again this is said
to be a multiversal illuminati so i'm
guessing they each come from or at least
a few of them each come from separate
universes they're not all coming from
the same universe which makes you wonder
since they are being called the
illuminati by everybody if they're
communicating with each other between
these different universes or do they all
just come to our main mcu timeline and
then they team up from there i'm gonna
assume since professor x is the leader
and he has the ability to communicate
with people telepathically i'm gonna
assume that he's probably talked to
these people before and since the
universe is essentially going to be at
stake in multiverse of madness and wand
is going to play a pretty big part of
that instability perhaps they make the
decision as the illuminati perhaps an
illuminati of the multiverse in not just
one universe they make that decision to
go to our universe and try to stop wanda
together that's not confirmed that's
just my personal theory that i think
would be really really cool to see now
the end of one division that post credit
scene with her having the darkhold made
it very very clear that wanda is going
to be if not the most powerful being in
the mcu one of the most and remember how
jean grey kind of made waste to
professor xavier i'm going to assume
that the scarlet witch's powers in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness because of the darkholder going
to pretty much be at phoenix force
levels perhaps not as strong because you
know it's the phoenix force but pretty
dang powerful so i'm not sure that this
illuminati is going to be able to stop
her in fact i'm pretty sure they won't
but it is cool that we could be seeing a
possible live-action captain carter
hopefully played by haley atwell daniel
rpk actually did report about a month
ago that he has heard that captain
carter is going to be in multiverse of
madness and when i personally
interviewed the writer and director of
marvel's what if i asked them if captain
carter could make her way to the mcu and
they played pretty coy about it but they
said that they were hopeful however the
executive producer brad winterbomb did
say that yes now anything is possible
and they can cross over and i would
personally really love to see this group
obviously i would love to see professor
x charles xavier patrick stewart's
version in the mcu i would love to see
haley atwell as captain carter obviously
mordo already exists in the mcu as well
as monica rambo but balder the brave
thor's half-brother and an asgardian
would be pretty cool to see especially
ifriga has put the invulnerability spell
on him pretty much making it to where as
long as he's in anna's guardian realm
nothing can hurt him except for
mistletoe in fact at one point in time
odin regarded him as the bravest
asgardian so i would absolutely love to
see him in multiverse of madness and i
would love to see this whole thing play
out the scarlet witch fight the
illuminati i think it would be so cool
but let me know what you think about
this new report in the comments down
below if you love marvel and want to
stay up to date don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and for live updates you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter don't forget to hit that like
button and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof